hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
where us GameSpot nerds and you talk
about the things that we like and today
we're talking about Westworld season 1
episode 8 trace decay so let's jump in
okay guys so first we're gonna talk with
our audience
first thing I wanted to correct buddy on
something so let's let's get that out of
the way buddy everyone I'm very sorry
for saying
dilio smoothly and prostrate myself
before you yes but it was called that
sir and it's HB we also have a comment
from a Bandhan on
Pandey who said I think Charlotte is a
host because during the last interaction
between 3:7 ford he told her about the
representative coming from the board
what it and what is noteworthy during
the peacock speech ford mentioned his
arrangement with the board which is too
precious for either one of them now it
begs the question is Delos in on it are
they colluding with Ford or some hidden
agenda is the whole park and everyone in
it part of a social experiment what do
you guys think I think that it would be
so interesting if like the end of the
show was like alright let's close it up
like weird like they just wanted to see
what happens if they put like some you
know millionaire philanthropist through
this thing where he tests his morals and
comes out insane like the whole thing is
just the matrix yeah yeah I think you're
right I think they're gonna I mean just
from what they've dropped on us now
that's you know kind of mind-blowing
you're like oh my gosh they're gonna hit
us hard at the end and it's gonna be
something yeah everybody's yeah we'll
get their predictions at the end let's
jump into trace decay let's talk about
this episode so we were disproven Teresa
is not coming back as a host but they
were making a host down there in the
basement when Teresa got killed
I think it's Elsie they were making an
LC bot and Ford is using LLC's vacation
time to create her and bring her back
because how are they gonna cover up two
deaths at once that will be very system
one thing about that yeah if bernard
killed LC yes we will we're all under
the impression that somebody on team
team dillos did it
but if Bernards working for Ford and
Ford is kind of anti del O's what the.oh
happened down there I don't know I have
no idea but I was really confused by
that I think Teresa was using that base
to send Delos information because
they're like yeah LT was like yeah the
last person to send stuff here was
Teresa so she was doing that there but
Bernard was also doing some secret
Arnold stuff down there I think I'm also
really confused by the timeline because
he was totally on the phone with LC then
all of a sudden he shows up and chokes
her out we all know they screw with us
yeah so she's gonna come back as LC
bought pretty sure let's jump into some
Dolores stuff so Dolores is all messed
up and she asked the question that all
of us as viewers were asking when are ya
catch what what do you think of this
hold Dolores thing do you have a theory
on this so I actually do have a theory
where I think Dolores is actually Wyatt
because they even made a whole point
where the rider is sinking he's building
Wyatt and he gets quickly corrected like
that's not Wyatt Ford's really deep in
his story why it's already probably in
play meaning it's probably someone we
know and then this episode we see
Dolores finding the town and having this
flashback and seeing like herself
killing off all the people in that town
and it's a very same type of scene that
Teddy keeps picturing when Wyatt killed
everyone and it seemed like all leads
are pointing back like to that area and
it just seems like she could very well
be Wyatt this whole time and she's just
now remembering everything it's a famous
street corner you do see that one single
shot from her point of view that's a
different shot but hold on Teddy sees a
dude
Teddy sees an image me he doesn't we
never see the face of who
exactly if memories are distorted I must
have a guy on the street corner didn't
he walk up to a dude and they like
looked at each other or am I wrong
well memories can be altered is what
we've learned so he can say that's a
thought he saw dude but this entire time
with a she Dolores
like Dolores keeps to herself in these
things and she's trying to remember what
the heck happened back then up until now
though they've not shown us things this
this was they showed us something else
like a man and you're saying in place of
a woman they mess with us was time I
mean maybe they'll mess with us with
what gender as well that makes sense
yeah very well could so that's you
when are we often the tune timeline
theory again how many timelines are
there that's the question it's like I
have no idea where we are when we are
and because we talked about this too lot
to timeline theory and went back and
forth then we're like the man in black
is is William and this and that now I
think it's I mean of course we know
there's tons of time once you have
Dolores bringing up Arnold to William
and he's kind of like I'm here let's go
so that was kind of interesting to be
like okay everybody knows who Arnold is
except William so what's going on there
I think now the question is how many of
these characters have been in all the
timelines you know who who has been
there the longing for Dove courses is
there as if nard 2 is where did these
characters overlap right - speaking of
MIB and other host of timelines heat we
see him in Maeve's timeline so the whole
tragic backstory that Maeve has in her
memories that she's her calling was it
might be just testing it out to see how
he would feel if he killed a woman and
her kid which was super meta stuff yeah
but then she went they brought her in to
fix her up she was still freaking out
about the kid and that's kind of the
start of Maeve recollecting things and
not being able to let go and just be the
special kind of host and now she can
control other hosts
so I think he's building her army and I
think she's gonna we were shown that
whole like basically refrigerator of
hosts that are in play right now and
she's just gonna activate them all
they'll be part of her army right buddy
do you have any thoughts on mais uh
Maeve in particular I mean I think HBO
did a great great job for all of the you
know adolescent males watching show they
had a scene of Nathan a reflection where
you got to actually see six boobs
there's what actress she says something
and does something with one of the the
texts that they were having some type of
discussion she says even at a fourteen
you're no match for blab like gives the
guy a number yeah so either she's just
assigning a random like Dean the
charisma number to this dude arbitrarily
or host like the techs are hosts also I
don't know how human beings work but
maybe you can't solder someone's really
rarity yeah yeah in this episode there
was a lot like even really quick before
we jump out
oh he's starting to remember so he's
retaining his memories of seeing I might
be before there was just one little
thing I don't really have any theories
about about Teddy at this moment but so
there was a mine at or right yeah a maze
and a mine at or they're just throwing
like a Holcomb tribe stuff at us and
weird like I don't know it's great Mayan
towards Greek I think the Knights he got
some serious hits on on the men in black
yeah I did think was cool it was a
picture of that Minotaur on the writers
wall was like clearly he was involved in
creating that
like what else has he created for why I
really what else does white have under
control so yeah we've got two episodes
left guys
two left any predictions Before we jump
out I predict that they won't cleanly
and anything so we're left like this for
an entire season
they are renewed for a sink we're gonna
find out a lot of people are hosts that
we were not expecting like I think Maeve
might even turn Bernard or try to
rewrite stories of people outside of
West world now that she had that crazy
affordability I think some people are
going to like help some hosts escape and
then they're gonna explode and then they
just slowly walk away my recurring for
dazzle host yeah he did say he did refer
to himself a couple times as a man this
time or he said we when talking about
humans but he also said something creepy
to Barnard which was like you're not the
first man referring to Barnard as a man
to threaten me which means I think that
sometimes he doesn't differentiate
between hosts and men and it's like yeah
so in case you guys thought that my
theory was disproved by his speech
patterns they don't have a match towards
a host this correct buddy on something
else this week leave it in the comments
below we have changes to the show guys
we do we are taking your comments as you
saw earlier in this episode we're
rolling your comments in so give us your
theories we will work them into the
episodes will give you credit if you
were right we were wrong
all right guys any last theories sketch
I do think Barnard is starting to get
more and more credence of being Arnold
like some of the questions he started
asking Ford we're very similar questions
that Arnold had once asked him and Ford
even made a point to note that to him
saying like you also like there was
another man that it asked me these same
questions
and so I started to think like Bernard
could very well be made in Arnold image
like he might have created Bernard to
look like him I still agree with that
yeah either that or Arnold's uploaded
into Dolores yeah both so it's not just
us lyric theories you are also leaving
theories for us so please leave them in
the comments below we'll work them into
the next episode
we've only got two episodes left so help
us come up with some theory aids and
we'll talk about it next week and for
all things nerding out sick of GameSpot
universe